good morning John so you might remember
that when I was a little kid I was
diagnosed with a learning disability I
sensory dysfunction basically sensory
disorders are when you either have a
hard time dealing with the information
you have coming into you or you have too
much information you're not getting
enough information what is the
information here I'm talking about stuff
coming into your senses not like stuff
you're learning but just everything
coming at you all the time if I'd been
born ten years later I probably would
have been additionaly or alternately
diagnosed with ADHD I can't say for sure
of course but when I was seven years old
which is the average age for an ADHD
diagnosis attention deficit disorders
just weren't being diagnosed or
discussed as much I definitely had
symptoms that don't fit into the
attention deficit box but are sometimes
overlapping conditions like mild
dyslexia and motor control problems on
the other hand I definitely do have some
attention issues schedules can be really
frustrating for me I have a hard time
being in the place where I'm supposed to
be at the right time everyone who works
with me can tell you that I'm sorry
everyone when I am able to focus on
things which is actually pretty
frequently I get really focused and when
I am forced to disengage from that focus
I get irrationally angry I'm always
searching for new things to create you
might have also noticed that and I wear
holes really fast in my socks because my
toes never stop moving they're going
right now I've gotten pretty good at
managing these things with the help of
friends and family and tutors and
teachers and thank God an assistant now
how did I ever function without hell but
I still often hurt people's feelings or
annoying them by going somewhere else in
my head when people that I care about
are talking to me as I previously said
I'm often late for stuff which makes
people think that I don't care about
them sometimes I have very difficult to
control flashes of rage in grocery lines
but here is a general thing about
psychological disorders which we're
discussing now on our new channel
scishow psyche by the way ice orders are
only classified as disorders when
they're ongoing frustrating impairment
and I especially now am less impaired by
the different way that my brain may be
work that's because of great support
from family and from teachers and it's
because I've gotten myself into
situations where the different way that
my brain works is actually maybe an
advantage rather than a hindrance and
it's also because of like economics my
parents took me to a handwriting
therapist who was like can you get this
kid a computer because she needs to
learn how to kite like
this person is a professional person who
makes people write better and they're
like get this child a computer and the
fact that getting a computer was an
option for my family back in like the
80s and that then I had this tool in my
home that none of my other classmates
had that allowed me to develop a skill
set that's none of my other classmates
all those things are huge there's kind
of two parts to minimizing the negative
effect of your brain not working normal
changing the environment to suit the
brain and then there's improving the
functionality of the brain itself
through things like medication or
mindfulness or exercise because of the
advantages I've had I've been pretty
successful at doing that first thing
means I kind of maybe didn't ever have a
hard enough time to look into the second
thing so do I have ADHD maybe but I am
definitely dedicated to doing my best to
understand my own shortcomings and to
develop techniques and habits to deal
with them and I've learned some of those
habits by living inside of my own body
but I've learned others from people who
have ADHD and are talking openly and
honestly about it and also from people
who work with people with attention
disorders I think right now I've gotten
through the hardest part of living in my
brain you know like figuring out how to
cope for all the ways in which my mind
isn't perfect for the situations it
finds itself in I am proud of that I
think that it took a lot of hard work
but it also took a lot of help help that
I got in spades because of my economic
advantages because I was diagnosed with
a sensory processing disorder early on
and I had a lot of great tutors in short
I've been very lucky and I've had lots
of help if you think that you might have
ADHD I have a video to recommend for you
it's very good it was the thing that
inspired me to make this figuring out
how to live in your own mind and your
own body is like the task of your life
and there's no reason to think that you
have to take that on alone John I'll see
you on Tuesday this by the way is the
reason why there's blue paint all over
my hoodie